let's talk a macro environment first uh
stuff's messed up it just seems to be
breaking to say the least what is your
analysis that's like where we are today
right like when you when somebody says
hey what's going on in the economic
world like how do you describe where we
are yeah well I think if you zoom out
and then zoom out and then zoom out
again right so a big thesis I've been
working on for about a year and a half
is like three revolutionary cycles that
are converging that are changing the
world so we have a 250 year political
revolution cycle every 250 years the
world the pendulum swings from
centralization and swings back to
decentralization right 250 years ago was
the American Revolution pushed back on
the centralization of the monarchy set
up a decentralized republic government
250 years before that Protestant
Reformation so we have that on this
cycle on an 80-year cycle there's a
financial Revolution cycle 80 years ago
Bretton Woods agreement et cetera on a
50-year cycle there's a technological
Revolution cycle every 50 years there's
been five of them and we're in the sixth
one right now so all three are
converging right now so that's like
super high level when you zoom in you
see that in real life so we had like
this war of globalism right now the weft
Davos Europe right ECB et cetera and so
I think the world is breaking apart
because of that because it's on this
time frame
and then of course it's being
exaggerated played out in real time with
Russia Ukraine China Supply chains
breaking down uh this morning we saw um
India and a bunch of other countries are
Banning exports of food so now countries
are starting to hoard food hoard
precious metals horde Commodities and so
it's starting to break apart really
really quick has there ever been a point
in time where those three Cycles the 250
year the 80-year and the 50-year Cycles
all converge around the same time Point
yeah back in uh back at the Industrial
Revolution in the late 1700s and so what
was uh kind of your analysis of okay
these three things converged what
happened then uh well the the world
swings back to decentralization right so
uh things start getting more and more
centralized Central planners right more
control and then it starts breaking
apart so
um the last 250 years we've been on the
path to centralization so we went from
the Industrial Revolution led to that
right so in the before the Industrial
Revolution it was Agricultural Society
so people were just in the farms and
cottage industry and that started
bringing people into cities into
factories then you had to be in the
United States you had to be in New York
you had to be in Chicago right and so it
led to that and now it's starting to
swing back the other way so we haven't
really seen this for uh 250 years so put
the technology piece aside for a second
put the financial uh component aside
what does that mean for an average
person you know over the next 10 20
years so is it everyone's going to go
live out in the woods and you know kind
of be on their own they already are I
mean look what happened with covid right
because covet forced people to work from
home so now look at real estate in
Colorado or Wyoming or Idaho people
always wanted to live there but they
never were able to and now real estate
there is blowing up because people can
go live there now but not just that now
they're going into Cancun in Mexico
they're going to Florianopolis in Brazil
right so now we're starting to see these
areas starting to blow up so the world
will continue to decentralize because
people will be able to go live and work
in those places what is the financial
impact across asset prices when
something like this happens well uh the
use you said to remove the tech piece
but you can't because the technology is
what is is what always changes things so
when you look back through history it's
always technology that drives these and
so these in these technological
revolutions they're different than
Technologies Technologies like an iPhone
I took a computer on a phone put them
together that's cool technological
revolution has two main components one
it changes the course of humanity and it
drives financial markets so there's been
five industrial revolution steam engines
and Railways
um steel and electricity oil Automobiles
and then 1971 the microprocessor which
brought us personal computers
telecommunications and the internet so
those all change the course of humanity
I don't need to go through that but they
also drove financial markets what's been
the financial markets last 40 50 years
Telecom internet what was before that
for GM GE what was before that steel oil
so when you look at it from financial
implications for most people you can see
how that's going to start changing in
the shorter term how is it going to
start changing so as the world starts to
break apart which it already is
going to change a lot of things so for
example just this morning and throughout
the course of the week but this morning
Japan announced that they're backing off
of their EV mandate
um Germany announced with I think three
other European countries uh last week
that they offer as well so the the
globalists the European Union have these
mandates to transition to EV Vehicles
right like a hundred percent by 2035 and
now they're all backing off of this so
they're like well I guess this isn't
going to work we need 60 countries to
get the minerals to make one EV vehicle
and now that countries aren't able to
cooperate and a lot of these countries
like I said are Banning exports I guess
this transition probably isn't going to
be possible so now we're starting to
revise that so when it comes to like
financial markets when you're betting on
things like EV Transitions and Booms
like that I think you have to be aware
of that so when you start trying to
analyze what's happening right now
there is a technology there's a finance
component to it and then there's this
like decentralization component I mean
the elephant in the room is it sounds
like Bitcoin is a huge piece of that how
do you kind of think through what is
occurring in the moment right now so you
talked about a swing back towards
decentralization
um what is the technology Revolution
that's going to change the course of
humanity and like what is the impact on
financial markets then well the and this
is a piece that I talked about at this
event I was at this weekend George
gammon's event shout out to Rebel
capitalist
um what people are missing and Lynn
Alden put out a quote last week to
equate Bitcoin and crypto
shows you don't understand either
and so I use that quote in my talk and
there's a technological Revolution
that's happening here but most people
are blinded to it because of the crypto
boom and bust that's been happening but
there's actually a revolution that's
happening so for the first time ever
we've created digital scarcity we've
created true decentralization we've been
able to now move into the information
age without copying information
which is like incredibly powerful now
what does that mean we don't really know
when steel was invented it gave us a new
material that we could build skyscrapers
and bridges with it also gave us
material we could build a space shuttle
with but we didn't know that when steel
came out right when electricity came out
the first application was a candle
um it was like a digital candle but
candles were light for 5 000 years what
did we do that for but it gave us the
building block to do what we're doing
right now and so we have a new set of
building blocks we don't know exactly
what we built off of that but I think
it's a you know I would imagine you
would agree it's probably the best
risk-adjusted investment that we could
make right now if we're willing to wait
so when you use the electricity example
or the steel example those were building
blocks as you mentioned um and in
hindsight we know that okay yes the
first applications were interesting uh
but they were uh really small compared
to what eventually was possible is the
revolution driven or like The Innovation
the blockchain is it Bitcoin as an
application of a blockchain like how do
you think through because I immediately
jumped like okay what were the critics
say of uh the Bitcoin only Viewpoint
they're like yes of course the
blockchain is the Innovation and then
we're gonna go put all these different
um you know applications and it's a
building block and all that how do you
think through is it actually the
blockchain or is it the application of
Bitcoin that ends up being the like the
true Innovation that serves as the
foundation for whatever is to come I
believe that the true Innovation is
decentralization okay interesting so how
do we achieve decentralization we
achieve decentralization by instead of
having one database we have multiple
databases in order to achieve that
everyone must be able to run a database
so with Bitcoin anyone in a third world
country with a five-year-old laptop can
download the database and run it but you
can't do that with any other of the
other whatever 19 000 coins and so the
The Innovation is decentralization
and I believe there's only one that
really gives us that it's not it's not
just decentralization though right it's
like a technology coordinated
decentralization that is operating uh
like my mind jumps to uh Balaji screen
of Austin's whole idea of like you know
these uh cloud-based economies or these
cloud-based societies where uh really
the decentralization is the ability to
coordinate via technology across the
world in a digital format I don't think
that's it okay explain in biology is
super smart by the way so shout out to
him he's he's like a walking
encyclopedia is insane right
um but I don't think that's it right I
think what it really is is it's it's
decentralization that makes it where
nobody controls The Ledger It's All
About The Ledger right if I have a coin
um and I give you the coin you have the
coin if I have the coin I have the coin
but if we do it in an Information Age we
need a ledger that shows who has the
coin yep now who controls the Ledger
that's the Crux of the matter right so I
think the oldest problem that mankind
has had is how do I protect my property
from being stolen so we make a tribe A
Village a kingdom a country but now if
nobody can control The Ledger then
nobody can steal my asset and if I want
to send it to you nobody can stop it
block and prevent it so digital
coordination is great don't get me wrong
it's going to be massive for production
and and things like that and of course
when we have this globalization we can
all collaborate together and we can get
more progress that's awesome that's
great but that that doesn't prevent
people from manipulating The Ledger yeah
I think we're saying the exact same
thing which is uh there's only one truly
decentralized uh Ledger today right in
terms of the ability to know what I have
is I have and if I send it to you no one
can stop me right right there's a lot
that aspire to do that claim to do it
whatever but there's only one that is
truly decentralized uh when I was
talking about this kind of like Cloud
economy or whatever it's just now we
have the ability in a digital format um
if you think of uh balaji's uh whole
idea of like there's gonna be three
currencies in the future there's like
the United States dollar uh there's the
Chinese and then there's Bitcoin yeah
right and it's like one of those three
ends up quote-unquote winning I think
you and I both lean towards well the
decisions and there'll be many it'll be
many right I mean think about the dollar
took over the reserve currency of the
world from the pound sterling but that
was a 40-year process but the pound
sterling is still being used today it's
really hard to kill currencies right
it's really hard to kill currency so I
think I believe as the world moves to
become more decentralized instead of the
one one Reserve currency of the world
everyone's waiting for the final moment
it's decentralized so maybe my Reserve
is different maybe microstrategies
Reserve is different maybe El Salvador
Reserve is different but other people
use other things so this is an
interesting point so you think that as
we move more and more towards a
decentralized world it won't be one
single Global Reserve currency whether
that's Bitcoin or a fiat currency you
think actually that there will be many
Reserve currencies and it's almost like
Choose Your Own Adventure what is the
currency that you need and which one do
you choose as your reserve currency well
which nation puts a hundred percent of
their reserves in one asset today none
none yeah they help use multiple
reserves right so we saw Russia what
happened with Russia they had their FX
Reserve Seas which were multiple
currencies not just one multiple
currencies but they also had other
assets Commodities Etc so no country
puts 100 of the reserves into one thing
so I think we're looking at it from the
wrong perspective by doing that the bis
put out this piece last week I'm sure
you saw because I know you're all over
the news but the bis put out this piece
and he talked about the soul of money
um and he said the soul of money is
based off trust and uh for whatever
centuries we've trusted Central Bankers
first of all money has no soul but I do
believe money is based off of trust and
I think what happened with Russia
Ukraine and the and the world basically
not just the us but the world moving
against Russia's FX Reserve was more
profound than most people think because
it was the death of trust and if you've
ever been in a relationship with a a
girlfriend a partner a wife a business
partner whatever when trust is lost
trust is lost and I think the world just
realized that we can't trust whoever
holds The Ledger why do you think it was
so profound explain more in detail in
terms of like what you think the
ramifications of all these Financial
sanctions against Russia are well
because as I said we seized we the
whatever the world there was multiple
currencies but their FX reserves were
seized Frozen
and so that money was on This Global
Ledger through the Swift system the
payment system and it was just frozen
and seized and so how can we trust our
money if it can just be taken away did
you see uh the commentary from Vladimir
Putin uh last week it was translated and
I always caveat this with uh we have to
accept it as a fact based on the
information we have today if somebody
disproved it later or something I don't
speak Russian yeah right so I'm somewhat
relying on the translations but it was a
fairly well articulated pretty honest
assessment and in in it I think you have
to separate out who's saying it versus
what's being said and if you can do that
which is hard but but if you can do that
uh one of the things he talks about is
this which is uh why would any
nation-state go ahead and now uh
increase their dependency or keep their
dependency on a system which is
dependent on the owners the us or G7
Nations or whatever
continuing to be friendly to them right
it's not only uh that it happened to
Russia I think to your point it's every
country in the world now is asking
themselves whoa hold on a second here
we're cool today yeah is there a world
in the future where we're not cool and
even if I can't see that world maybe I
don't want to bet on us still being cool
in the future and I may do some things
differently which brings us all the way
back to the actual Revolution which is a
decentralized ledger
so what he's saying is whoever controls
The Ledger has the power and it becomes
a very political tool and so we almost
need a decentralized ledger that nobody
can control which is kind of what he was
hinting at I think
um and I think you know Russia is one of
three Global superpowers with nuclear
weapons so what chance do tier two tier
three nations have none none none zero
um how important is it that Russia's FX
uh it wasn't just sanctions you cannot
uh send this anywhere so for example we
just saw G7 go ahead and ban Uh Russian
gold right gold from Russia yeah and
they said hey we are not going to allow
our countries to import this in and so I
think of that as almost the the
transacting of the asset but that
doesn't mean that the United States or
any of the other g7s uh took gold out of
Russia right it's more so just we're
gonna keep it in your country we're not
going to do business on this uh specific
uh transaction kind of rail
but also there was the seizing of FX
reserves as well and it's because Russia
was keeping those reserves in other uh
kind of custody right outside of their
own we have no choice unless you print
it out and put it in pallets this is
gonna be my question is in the Legacy
world can you do self-custody in any
kind of scalable uh way if you're a
country with the types of assets and
size that they have you can with gold
but the problem is is it's hard to move
gold around so Venezuela had gold but
they were keeping it in the UK vaults
but the UK seized two billion worth of
Venezuela's gold so then it's like well
shoot I guess I have to have my gold in
my country and so you start to see the
problem that we have and it gets to this
drug dealer moment was like give me the
drugs no give me the money right and uh
so it gets very difficult to do business
that way
I think uh uh yeah I think it just
further proves like how do we move
forward in a way where the world has
Global cooperation without the ability
to pay on some sort of a rail that can't
be seized what is the difference between
how countries are going to think about
this and kind of analyze where the world
is going versus individuals or is it the
same exact analysis well I think I think
so now when we go back to adding the
three Cycles together we have the
financial Revolution cycle and so I
think what we're starting to see really
quickly the world is being slapped in
the face this morning Japan announced
they're coming back off that EV mandate
what we're realizing really quickly is
that um in a world where we print
unlimited amounts of fake fiat currency
people want to buy real hard things so
we have this commodity super cycle right
we have this massive under investment
into Commodities and now today we have
this massive shortage and the central
banks have found out very quickly we
can't print more energy or more food and
so the world's been slapped in this face
and so we're starting to see this kind
of transition going back to that and so
I think that's kind of how the world is
starting to be reshaped and we're
starting to see that real things are
worth real like real things right and
this feels like a continuation if you go
back to uh covid uh early on I think uh
chamoth palapatia I talked with him and
uh one of the insights that he had
almost immediately was hey the world uh
but specifically the United States has
pursued efficiency to the extreme yeah
and We've ran around the world looking
for this efficiency and we found it we
found cheaper labor we found a more
efficient Supply chains uh better
manufacturing all these different things
but in our pursuit of efficiency we gave
up the resilience that is necessary in
moments like in covid when you shut down
the global economy all of a sudden kind
of the United States was exposed and
we're like damn get those ships over
here right get those materials here we
need to import certain things because we
don't have the manufacturing or supply
chain set up here in America yeah and it
feels like what you're talking about is
a very similar uh Trend and almost as a
continuation of what we saw back in
2020. yeah well it is right because
these Cycles they hit but it's not like
like a season it's like summer starts on
this exact day but really the weather
kind of changes plus or minus a month or
two so we're seeing a transition over
this decade it's not like it happens on
a certain day so for sure it's it's all
part of this we've been transitioning
for like the last seven years
um so it's certainly part of that but
um there's other things that play as
well but as that continues to play out
also part of it is the triffin's
dilemmas I'm sure you're aware right the
nation has to reserve currency has to be
a net exporter right so we have to
export dollars to the world so which
means we had to Offshore all of our
manufacturing but also because all that
money printing was so inflationary then
we also had to offset that inflation by
Cheap you know Outsourcing cheap labor
et
cetera
um but I think that all that's coming to
a head obviously we can see it right and
uh the Nations that have the assets are
going to be the ones that move forward
in the next decade one of the big
critiques of deflationary system so
Bitcoin obviously being one on a
structural basis but but in general uh
deflationary systems is that you will
kill velocity of money and you will kill
any sort of true economic growth right
now
I always say okay that's one argument
there's another argument which is no the
loose monetary policy and the continued
devaluation of a currency essentially is
a financial incentive for people to get
rid of the cash so whether you invest or
you consume do it and unfortunately
Financial education is not uh very
pervasive in the United States or
elsewhere yeah and so most people they
consume uh rather than go and invest in
any material way and so because there
are so many people with this uh cheap
money that are sitting there ready to
consume it means that manufacturers
could create less and less high quality
goods and people are still wanting to
buy them and so in some way the
devaluation of the currency and the
loose monetary policy drove lower
quality Goods being flushed into the
system if we were to start to adopt a
deflationary system is it that the
actual velocity of money would slow down
or is it that people would only spend
the money for the most high quality
goods and in some way we would like wipe
the the bad consumerism and return back
to this like high quality goods and
service economy these are super in-depth
conversations to have and so you have to
look at cost benefit analysis on a bunch
of things so for example uh Fiat uh
safety and talks about Fiat money Fiat
food and so in order to hide that
inflation we've had to make food cheaper
cheaper cheaper we've substituted for
worse and worse products McDonald's used
to make their fries with Tallow which
was good for you now they make it with
seed oils which are very bad for you and
so in one of the Pursuits of making
things cheaper now we're making
ourselves more unhealthy so now we're
spending more on health care right and
so there's a lot of cost benefit
analysis there but I think to your point
about this inflation or I'm sorry the
velocity of money they believe that we
need to make people spend money because
if we don't they're going to hoard it
really I think people have no problem
spending money we all want more things
right that's human greed so we don't
need any help spending money we're
already going to spend money but there's
a conversation I had last night at the
conference and I think a lot of people
say that we need
um without if we were on a fixed
Monterey system like Bitcoin then
there's no credit markets without credit
markets then the economy would expand
very slowly the velocity would slow down
because now I can't go buy 10 houses I
can't expand my business go buy 10
trucks if I don't have the loans and we
don't know it's academic but maybe the
story of the tortoise or the hair and
maybe the economy would grow slower but
more steady and in a Fiat money system
we have more booms and busts and maybe
over a period of time we end up ahead
I um this I hate to admit this because
people will laugh but uh yesterday I was
actually watching a speech from Peter
Lynch uh who ran the Magellan fund at
Fidelity for you know however many years
uh and he gave it I don't know probably
two decades ago it seems like based on
the quality of the video uh to uh I
think it was the Washington Press Club
or something like that and in it he
talks about uh you know look investing
is really not that hard uh corporate
profits go up about eight percent a year
and the stock market goes up about eight
percent a year and like the entire point
of investing is if you buy something
today and it's still around 20 years
from now and it goes up about eight
percent in terms of corporate profits
like the the math would suggest that
this is also going to go about 80 a year
and when you start to look at that
you're like yes maybe 20 or 30 years ago
that was 100 true but that's not what we
were seeing for the last two years uh in
this loose monetary policy so in some
way the intervention into the market
ended up really diluting what many
people would have thought as like the
traditional signals of value or value
accrual right how do you think about
asset markets or asset prices when there
is this kind of manipulation of the
market and not necessarily in a
nefarious
um uh Pursuit as much as just like we
feel as humans we have to do something
so we're in control so let's intervene
every time there's you know a bad time
and then that ends up you know creating
these kind of asset bubbles if you will
yeah um Preston push put up a chart
yesterday that showed central bank
balance sheets and the S P 500 and I
mean they just move in lockstep right
and so if you want to look at all the
world markets and then and then break
them down into US dollar value and then
break out the monetary issuance or
expansion then you see that we haven't
actually gone up that much
um so I think it's pretty evident that
the central bank balance sheets have a
lot to do with these markets and these
asset prices and then um at the end of
the day I think most people don't really
understand the Crux of the matter and
the Crux of the matter is that we need
food we need energy we need goods and
services wealth is goods and services
wealth is not money and so what happens
is we get caught up in the US dollar
valuation of these stocks so he says
it's going up by eight percent a year my
stock pay percentage that's great but
what we really want is we want our money
to buy us more goods and services in the
future we want our cost our you know we
want we want to be able to buy more
things for doing less work and so if our
asset prices are only going up with the
cost of inflation or the rise of the
price of inflation then we're not
getting any more purchasing power so
we're really not any better off in US
dollar terms oh my house is worth more
my stocks are worth more but if I sell
my house at this inflated value I can
only go buy the same exact house so I
haven't gained any purchasing power and
the idea is something like Bitcoin
obviously is different than that well it
could be it could be and one thing I
would say about Bitcoin is a lot of a
lot of critics I was the only only
Bitcoin person at this event so I have
to deal with this all weekend but a lot
of people a lot of people expect it to
be what it support what it could be in
the future they expect it to be that
today if we were walking through the
forest and here's a little oak tree this
big I'm like hey pump check this oak
tree out can you imagine this little
thing is going to be giant one day and
you're like no way look how small I
think it'll never be big it's like no
it's an oak tree it will be no it can
never be right and so like bitcoin's on
Evolution path right now it's volatile
right if you live in a third world
country then you're trying to use
Bitcoin every day and you're trying to
you know put your money for food in that
like it's volatile and that could be
dangerous which you know maybe a lot of
people think CB or not cbdc's but stable
coins could work in conjunction with
Bitcoin in some of these countries and
so it's not the best it's not the most
stable currency today so all these
critics want to say it's not a good
currency well it's probably not today
because it's super volatile but it has
been a good store of value if you can
zoom out and look over a long period of
time so is it the best store of value
over the last six months no it's up 20
in the last seven days uh it's down 65
in the last eight months but it's also
up 450 in the last 24 months so depends
on what kind of time frame so if you
want to it's it's on its path to
becoming a store of value and then
eventually I think you can move on to a
medium Exchange in your recent
presentation you talked about the idea
of uh Bitcoin not so much a blockchain
as much as a time change yeah uh which
is a very unique concept yeah explain
what this means time chain not
blockchain so in satoshi's white paper
he never used use the word blockchain
and so and you mentioned earlier is
blockchain the Revolution and I'm guilty
of that I got into Bitcoin in 2015. in
2016 I started writing a cryptocurrency
newsletter and from 2016 to 2019 I
published a thousand pages of research
on cryptocurrencies and I was like hey
it's blockchain it's not Bitcoin so I I
was guilty but after publishing a
thousand pages of research I was like
nope that's not it but back to the time
chain in the white paper he used the
word time chain
and uh Gigi put out this article how
time is money but money is time and so
time has an order of things and so
basically the time chain keeps order
keeps time of these blocks being added
one time after another and the
importance of that back to this
revolution it gives us this new Ledger
that keeps track of time and we can do
all types of things we don't know so in
a good example as a consensus two weeks
ago I was down there in Austin and they
announced Dorsey announced web five like
it's whatever web for it's a meme right
but but what they introduces with these
dids right so Daniel bird has been
working with ion Microsoft right now
these dids and these decentralized
identifiers where I can control my ID my
data instead of having to log in with
Facebook or Google I can now keep my ID
right and they use the Bitcoin
blockchain to put that hash in to keep
that record so now we have this
decentralized Ledger that nobody can
control and we can use it for things
like a did that we wouldn't be able to
do that before if we put it into another
chain pain that could be hacked or
manipulated or whatever so so we're
starting to see how this time chain can
be used for other types of things like
this did and when you think of the time
chain uh one of the um kind of nice
things on Twitter that I've seen which
uh every time I see it it just makes me
smile even though I know what they're
doing uh is a number of people I've seen
recently announced the birth of their
child and rather than say you know kind
of the historic uh or historical uh on
this date at this time the baby was born
this whatever they just put what is the
block I haven't seen that oh yeah yeah
what what basically what block was you
know about block your baby's on I do I
do not uh to be honest with my first
child I was just making sure that the
baby was there oh my wife was good all
that but yeah when I saw you know people
started to do this over the last couple
of months I was like man that is so cool
because now all of a sudden it's not
like oh on uh June 4th at 1103 uh p.m uh
you know eastern time and you're like
okay GMT to EST like you just get rid of
all that it's just here is the actual
blog talk in which this occurred and
that block is the same uh across the
world right which goes back to this idea
of a Time chain and if you could almost
standardize time not based on uh some
sort of geography which we have today
with time zones but instead you can
actually have a globally agreeable time
it's pretty powerful yeah because if you
think about who keeps the ledger so if
we were both using the same bank account
we both had debit cards and we're in
different parts of the world so you run
a transaction I run a transaction and
then that ledger is trying to reconcile
that but to your point we're in
different time zones so which
transaction came in first you're a day
ahead of me a day behind me Etc and so
it creates that problem and again it's a
building block we don't know what can be
built on top of it but I hadn't really
thought of that but I think it's a great
illustration what's the craziest thing
you think is possible Right obviously
understand this is a building block and
we can only see so far into the future
it's super foggy when you look too far
but like what is the thing that you're
like you know what I I do think that
this will happen
what I think happens more than anything
is changing the incentive structures of
the world
um in Bitcoin Miami
um Breedlove had a good conversation
with Jordan Peterson and they talked
about how if everybody's playing the
game everybody's playing together and
everyone's productive because everyone's
enjoying playing the game and they're
working together but if half the people
had to step out of the game to enforce
the remaining half to play the game
you've lost productivity because now
half the people have to force the other
people but also when they're forcing the
other half of the people they don't
really want to play anymore so their
productivity goes down and that's kind
of the environment that we're in today
so imagine if we change the incentive
structure to where everybody can play
the game together how much better the
world could be we have a Fiat money
system that's losing value so we used to
be able to save money in dollars today
we used to we we've uh we've had
progress because the specialization of
Labor right so if I could be the best
brain surgeon I could be maybe I could
change the world but today I have to be
half brain surgeon half investor yeah I
talk all the time about uh we ask
teachers to go be the best teachers in
the world go be the best accountant go
be the best marketing manager or
whatever and then oh by the way nights
and weekends like become a great
investor here protect your purchasing
power yeah like that is so we've lost
massive mind share so I look at how much
different could the world be if
everybody was providing value as far as
what technologies can be built it's very
difficult humans are horrible at imagine
in the future we imagine better versions
of today we have cars we'll fly in cars
so if you look at uh books of the future
from 50 60 years ago they envisioned us
teleporting and spaceships we didn't do
that they didn't Envision you know
iPhones and things like that so uh it's
very difficult to say do you think that
the Innovation on top of Bitcoin will
come from the Bitcoin Community or do
you think it'll be an Outsiders who are
looking for some technology and realize
they can use Bitcoin but they aren't
necessarily bitcoiners in term uh as
they create the Innovation uh probably
eventually non-bitcoiners right so I
think what happens is I look at it like
a TCP protocol and there's trillions of
applications built on one protocol and
now we have a Bitcoin protocol and I
believe there will be trillions of
applications built on top of the Bitcoin
protocol eventually you know like this
Taro for example seems like a pretty
cool option where we could maybe we
launch other tokens on top of that a lot
of bitcoiners aren't super happy about
that but I think about like one of the
big revolutions is keeping property in a
way that can't be stolen for me and if I
want to send it to you nobody can censor
that right so think about before the
internet how did you have stocks your
stock certificates there were pieces of
paper that would keep in my safe and if
I had the stock certificate a bear
instrument or a bond right I would have
that bare instrument and almost if you
could put assets back into Bearer
instruments where I could hold them and
we could exchange them freely so I think
that's probably a big innovation that
could happen and I think we'll start to
see a lot of stuff come on that aren't
bitcoiners uh eventually you know
they'll just be building companies I I
was investing in the early days of
the.com in the late 90s
and I remember at the time I was young
just starting my investing career my
roommate quit his job and we're trading
these things called internet stocks
everyone thought we were crazy they
never heard of these things but today
there's no such thing as Internet stocks
they're just companies yeah uh last
thing I want to talk about is uh tarot I
think it's a really interesting way to
kind of apply a thought process as to
where this could be going uh so for
those that don't know you have Bitcoin
layer one uh we then get Layer Two on
top of that trying to make it more
scalable cheaper uh faster uh which is
lightning Network and now there's this
idea from lightning labs they put
forward called tarot and the idea is
that you would be able to create all
sorts of different assets on top of and
tie into eventually the layer one of of
Bitcoin via a decentralized ledger
correct yeah and so when you think about
that is if the world does move to a
fully Digital World which seems to be
the the overarching trend over the last
couple of uh of decades and centuries
even
is it one Ledger or do we end up getting
multiple ledgers and really it gets at
this point of like the bitcoiners that
are upset or don't like the idea of
tarot is it because they don't believe
that other assets will become digital
and need a decentralized ledger like why
are they not as excited about it maybe
as the people who are working on it well
a lot of people believe that we don't
need a bunch of tokens we need one and I
would agree in a sense right so we need
one money we don't need a bunch of money
so you know you talk about business
obviously the best business show and
part of a business is to reduce friction
yes you want to reduce friction as much
as possible I might have 15 minutes to
kill and there's Dave and Busters and I
might want to play a couple video games
but I don't want to go stand in line and
have to convert my dollars into the into
the stupid tokens and I I don't so
there's friction I won't even play right
so we want to reduce friction I could
see they're having one money but there
are other assets I'm we're going to
continue to have businesses people are
still going to want to invest into
businesses like we're still going to
have other assets that I don't see that
going away so the ability to own those
assets whatever they may be shares of a
real estate property shares of a company
um I could see those other assets need
eating a way to own them and hold them
and have custody of them and so I think
having tokens is a way to do that it's
so fascinating because uh I've used the
example in the past of uh why do people
invest to get more dollars right if
you're in the United States and so your
whole idea is I'm gonna take dollars I'm
gonna put it in some other asset that is
going to outpace uh the growth or
decline of the dollars and then when I
sell I will get more dollars uh in the
Bitcoin world there's a lot of folks who
think of it as I'm gonna take my dollars
I'm going to convert it to bitcoin this
decentralized digital currency and I'm
gonna hold that
but it's hard for me not to see a world
where there's people who say okay I have
Bitcoin and I have three Bitcoin I'm
going to invest so that something
outpaces and then I get five Bitcoin and
if Bitcoin becomes your reserve currency
uh then naturally you're gonna want more
and more of it and that would be a
metric for gaining wealth I think the
critique of that Viewpoint is what's
going to outpace you know Bitcoins 125
compounding growth rate of the last
decade
it's like how do you think about that
like is it that the compound annual
growth rate will go down over time and
eventually you'll have to invest to get
more or like what do you think yeah of
course of course it does you can't keep
going up like that right forever I go
back to history so how did it work on a
gold standard
people saved gold they consumed less
than they earned and they lent it out
right and the rich people would lean
lend to the Kings and the governments
right go back and watch Game of Thrones
right so the rich people are loaning
money out so people
um earn less than they consume and then
they um loan it back out and so people
always do that obviously at some point
uh you know we're gonna have to see that
the uh the rate of of increase is going
to go down but I just go back to that
history shows us how it works and people
are always going to want to lend for
more yield and to increase what they
have and we're going to need economic
growth people are still going to have
ideas to create new products and new
things and they're going to need startup
Capital to do that and people are still
going to be willing to lend money for
that yeah where can we send people to
find you on the internet I feel like
more people need to hear your ideas and
kind of your thoughts yeah I think just
go uh just on Twitter at onemark Moss
the number one or just uh at
onemarkmos.com I have links to
everything on there uh do a couple hours
a week on iHeartRadio nationally
syndicated radio show and the podcast
and my YouTube channel and on and on and
on
um I uh just dropped the link in the
chat for anyone who wants to uh go
follow him uh last question actually is
um you always seem to be very high
energy similar to me I try to be high
energy yeah one of our sponsors is eight
sleep I sleep on the Sleep mattress love
it what's your sleep schedule I see you
have coffee so it's your caffeine
schedule and how do you keep high energy
throughout the day so um I haven't tried
that mattress I got a a Sleep Number bed
and I've been sleeping in a hotel I
can't wait to get out of my bed about
eight years ago I read Tim ferriss's
book tools of Titans and he talked about
this uh this state that some people get
in where this fog lifts off their brain
into this Crystal Clear thinking I was
like oh I want that and it comes through
fasting and then you have ketones start
going through your body and you get that
um and so I was like all right I'll skip
breakfast I'll do an 18 hour fast every
day uh but I love breakfast I don't know
if I can do it I can do it for two weeks
I'll commit to two weeks and if I you
know we'll see what happens and that was
eight years ago and I still do it every
day so I do have some coffee but I don't
eat I still do about 18 hour fast every
day what time do you eat for the first
time I usually eat about two o'clock two
two or three o'clock so like two to
eight o'clock or two to eight usually
like a six hour window got it and then
maybe twice a month I do like a 20 24.
so I don't eat uh breakfast either do
you eat more the bigger meal uh the
first one or the last one uh usually the
first one the first lunch would be a
really big meal yeah yeah and then you
eat a smaller meal uh for dinner yeah I
think that that's the only way to do it
or I get too hungry and then I start
eating crazy [ __ ] yeah because uh I'm
waiting for dinner yeah so I think
that's what really gives me the energy
it gives me that clear Focus that I was
after and uh it makes it easy too
because I don't have to think about what
I'm gonna eat every morning yeah
Relentless yeah that's the whole key
yeah exactly all right man listen thank
you so much for taking the time to do
this yeah thanks a lot and we'll
definitely have to get you on here more
often because it's a pleasure you've got
a number of ideas that people would
really benefit from yeah thank you